die luft im flugzeug so sauber wie in
einem operationssaal
das ist die these des bundesverbandes
der deutschen luftverkehrswirtschaft
demnach ist das fliegen auch während der
korona pandemie völlig unproblematisch
doch fachleute weltweit sehen das völlig
anders und welche
sicherheitsvorkehrungen gelten an bord
wie hoch ist die infektionsgefahr beim
flug in den urlaub wirklich und welche
möglichkeiten gibt es das
ansteckungsrisiko im flugzeug zu
minimieren krieg substanzen future gibt
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen krieg so
gibt es übrigens auch als rein
akustischen ohrenschmaus und zwar als
podcast für unterwegs der link ist hier
unter me und in der video beschreibung
aktuell steigt die zahl der neu
gemeldeten kroner infektionen wieder und
beim robert-koch-institut schrillen die
alarmglocken noch in der vergangenen
woche hatte der präsident des robert
koch-instituts lothar wieler gesagt dass
ihm die neueste entwicklung zitat große
sorgen bereite in der vergangenen woche
waren in deutschland rund 3600
infektionen gemeldet worden in der zeit
davor waren die fallzahlen stabil und
lagen bei täglich 300 bis 500 neu
gemeldeten fällen die fachleute führen
den derzeitigen anstieg zum teil auf
urlaubsrückkehrer zurück die das virus
aus dem ausland mit einschleppen
am wochenende 25 26 der juli waren am
neuen corona testzentrum am düsseldorfer
flughafen bei knapp 60 reisenden eine
infektion festgestellt worden
doch derzeit ist urlaubszeit und viele
wünschen sich ein stück normalität
zurück sie steigen in den flieger um
sich am anderen ende der welt zu
entspannen
doch dafür notwendig einen oft stunden
langer flug doch ist der flieger nicht
einer der ungünstigsten orte an denen
man sich während der korona pandemie
aufhalten kann kaum an einem ort sind
sich so viele leute so nah wie hier und
vor allen dingen auch solange das sind
teilweise hunderte menschen die eng
nebeneinander in einem geschlossenen
raum setzen eigentlich unvorstellbar in
diesen tagen wo doch viele
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vor einer zweiten welle waren
der bundesverband der deutschen
luftverkehrswirtschaft allerdings sieht
das keineswegs als
neben demnach sei das infektionsrisiko
in flugzeugen extrem gering die luft in
den kabinen sei vergleichbar mit der
luft in operationssälen garantiert
werden denn das durch spezielle filter
und den mund nasenschutz denen die
passagiere und die besatzung
verpflichten tragen müssen
die luft im flieger also ähnlich rein
wie in einem op
okay was sagen fachleute zu dieser
behauptung und kam es in den vergangenen
monaten bereits zu kroner übertragung in
einem flugzeug wie sicher ist das
fliegen in zeiten von corona also
wirklich genau um diese fragen geht es
in diesem video nach den leitlinien der
europäischen union zu flugreisen während
der korona pandemie muss nicht nur das
bordpersonal sondern auch alle
passagiere ab sechs jahren eine
medizinische schutzmaske tragen und zwar
ab dem betreten des flughafens bis zur
ankunft am reiseziel
die leitlinien sehen vor dass die masken
alle vier stunden gewechselt werden
sollen fluggesellschaften können
reisenden die keine maske tragen den
mitflug verweigern
die empfehlung der eu behörde für
luftfahrtsicherheit und der eu
krankheitsbekämpfung behörde ist es
außerdem die abstandsregeln einzuhalten
und zwar zitat im rahmen des möglichen
dazu könnte beispielsweise einen
sitzbereich oder aber sogar jede zweite
reihe im flugzeug zusätzlich
freigehalten werden keine frage dass den
airlines das gegen den strich geht denn
wenn plätze frei bleiben geht massig an
geld verloren
die internationalen luftverkehrs
vereinigung beispielsweise argumentiert
dass das fliegen in diesen fällen dann
nicht mehr wirtschaftlich sein
die redaktion des ard politmagazins
report mainz hatte ende mai einen
selbstversuch gestartet und die regeln
beim fliegen während der korona pandemie
genauer ins visier genommen die
ergebnisse waren ernüchternd denn die
regeln wurden bei weitem nicht immer
eingehalten am frankfurter flughafen
waren einige passagiere beim check in
und boarding gate ohne maske unterwegs
und die einweiser und ein weiteren
verantwortlichen wirkten überfordert mit
den vielen passagieren die teils dicht
gedrängt zusammen stand beim 1 und auch
beim aussteigen drängelten sich die
passagiere minutenlang im mittelgang des
flugzeuges also so wie es immer war und
kleine beobachtung meiner seite' immer
wenn ich geflogen bin lief die
klimaanlage um dies gleich noch geht
auch gar nicht während des einstiegs
also von wegen bedingungen wie im op und
da kommt noch mehr dazu auch im flugzeug
selbst während des fluges wurden die
sicherheitsvorkehrung also lange nicht
so eingehalten wie von der eu empfohlen
bei dem flug von frankfurt nach portugal
beobachteten die journalistinnen und
journalisten dass fast jeder mittelplatz
belegt war
dazu muss man sagen dass die eu-vorgaben
das tatsächlich erlauben wenn das
flugzeug ausgebucht ist in diesem fall
müssen abstandsregeln nicht eingehalten
werden das entsprechende protokoll mit
der bezeichnung cupid 19 aviation health
safety protokoll wurde am 20 mai 2020
veröffentlicht und kein einziger der
enthaltenen hinweise ist für die
airlines tatsächlich bin
es handelt sich einzig und allein um
empfehlungen eine der kernaussagen
lautet wenn körperliche abstand auf
grund der passagier last nicht
garantiert werden kann sollten sich
passagiere an andere vorbeugende
maßnahmen halten und eine gesichtsmaske
tragen wie kann das sein
wie kann es sein dass überall penibel
darauf geachtet wird und nur im flugzeug
plötzlich alles egal ist sind die
bedingungen im flugzeug also wirklich so
hygienisch wie im op-saal das
abstandhalten zählt mittlerweile seit
einigen monaten zu einer der elementaren
maßnahmen des gesundheitsschutzes in der
korona pandemie mindestens 1,5 meter
abstand sollten es zum schutze aller
sein wer sich nicht daran hält dem
drohte zeitweise sogar ein saftiges
bußgeld nur im flugzeug durfte und darf
das komplett anders sein der dachverband
der fluggesellschaften und die airlines
selbst argumentieren mit der masken
pflicht zudem sei auch der bordservice
wegen corona reduziert die klimaanlagen
an bord des flugzeugs würden die luft so
gut filtern wie es auch bei
krankenhäusern der fall sei die
ansteckungsgefahr werde weiterhin durch
die vertikale belüftung jedes einzelnen
sitzplatzes in verbindung mit den
schutzmasken ausreichend verringert
airbus beispielsweise schreibt dass die
luft in den kabinen alle zwei bis drei
minuten erneuert werde
dazu der airbus ingenieur john grease
gemocht die luft im flugzeug ist bei der
landung sauberer als nach dem schließen
der türen beim start durch den einsatz
von hochleistungs filtern habe die luft
in der kabine somit die qualität wie in
einem krankenhaus zu den
abstandsregelung sagte david powell
vom dachverband der fluggesellschaften
jemand hat gezeigt dass ein lehrer
mittlerer sitz die wahrscheinlichkeit
verringert 19 von einer person zur
anderen zu übertragen
das ist nicht ganz richtig hört man
gleich noch mehr dazu zudem hätten die
passagiere wenig gesichts kontakt sehen
während des fluges nach vorne und auch
die sitze würden als eine art barriere
dienen auf der anderen seite besteht
sogar airbus selbst ein
das einzige tatsächliche
gesundheitsrisiko besteht im kontakt von
person zu person durch niesen oder
husten wird die infektion über kurze
strecken durch tröpfchen übertragen
kein belüftungssystem ist eine anlage
dieser art der übertragung zu verhindern
in einer dpa meldung lässt der konzern
außerdem vermelden eine infektion durch
anhusten oder direkten kontakt ist
allerdings auch im flugzeug möglich
gerade wenn menschen eng beieinander
sitzen
warum dann kann mindestabstand fachleute
weltweit warnen schon seit anfang der
korona pandemie davor das fliegen in
dieser zeit auf die leichte schulter zu
nehmen
der us-wissenschaftler quinn yan chen
kann die argumentation der
fluggesellschaft nicht nachvollziehen er
bezeichnet volle flugzeuge als zitat
ziemlich gefährlich ein forschungsteam
von der purdue university aus den usa
und dem flugzeug ingenieur dieter scholz
aus hamburg hat nun eine simulation
erstellt diese offenbart ganz klar dass
das corona risiko flugzeug größer ist
als gedacht in der simulation hustet
oder niest eine person und es bildet
sich eine tröpfchen wolke laut dem us
forscher quinn yan chen von der purdue
university werden die tröpfchen zunächst
eher nach vorne geschleudert wenn eine
maske aufgesetzt wurde strömen die
tröpfchen bedingt durch den luftdruck
aus der lunge zwischen gesicht und maske
zur seite und nach oben und unten als
durch das filtermaterial hindurch darin
enthalten können natürlich auch virus
partikel sein die sich durch die
luftzirkulation in der kabine verteilen
hier sagt einem schon der gesunde
menschenverstand dass an dieser stelle
der abstand entscheidend ist dazu
schreibt der hamburger forscher dieter
scholz je größer der abstand ist desto
größer ist das volumen und je geringer
ist in diesem moment die dichte der
tröpfchen das entspricht ja schon der
intuition dass es einen unterschied
macht ob ich von jemandem aus kurzer
entfernung an
werde oder ob ich am anderen ende der
flugzeugkabine nur noch verdünnten wären
ausgesetzt bin nachdem sich die viren
über die ganze kabine verteilt haben
die tröpfchen dichte ist also geringer
wenn weiter entfernten nachbarn erreicht
werden als wenn der direkte sitznachbar
oder die direkte sitznachbarin getroffen
werden klar ist hierbei auch dass die
viren ausbreitung minimiert werden
könnte wenn sitze oder sogar ganze
reihen freigelassen würden nach den
berechnungen von dieter scholz könnte
das risiko einer infektion um den faktor
acht reduziert werden um den faktor acht
das ist echt schon der hammer wenn der
mittelsitz jeweils frei gehalten würde
mehr als leichtsinnig also dass die
politik genau das den airlines nicht
vorschreibt und zum haareraufen dass man
sich den abstand zum sitznachbarn bei
manchen airlines sogar erkaufen muss
diese machen damit also noch kohle bei
eur wings bleibt der mittelsitz gegen
einen aufpreis von 18 euro frei das ist
schon ein bisschen unappetitlich
gesundheitsschutz nur gegen cash zurück
zur studie verkürzt und vereinfacht
gesagt bleiben die teilchen der
aktuellen simulationen zufolge vier
minuten in der luft bevor diese von der
klimaanlage gefiltert wird zitat nach
vier minuten sind nur noch 12 prozent
der tröpfchen in der kabine verbieten
bei der hälfte der luft die in die
kabine gelangt handelt es sich übrigens
um sogenannte regulierte luft fachleute
meinen damit die luft die der kabine
entnommen wurde und dann mit hilfe von
stickstoff filtern gereinigt wurden
hierbei handelt es sich um hepa filter
das steht für high efficiency
particulate filters daher wohl auch der
vergleich mit den operationssälen denn
diese hepa filter werden tatsächlich
auch dort eingesetzt sie sind in der
lage wären zu filtern doch klar ist auch
dass die airlines hier äpfel mit birnen
vergleichen dazu heißt es auf der
webseite des hamburger wissenschaftlers
dieter scholz die luftfahrtindustrie
argumentiert verkürzt flugzeuge und
operationssäle haben hepa filter
daher ist die luftqualität gleich gut
entgegnung a
wenn jeder filter viren filtern sollten
regulation dann müssen die viren vorher
in der kabine noch vorhanden gewesen
seien
umkehrschluss die qualität der luft im
operationssaal ist vergleichbar mit der
im flugzeug wenn 200 personen um den op
tisch herum stehen und zu
im klartext heißt das also dass sich die
passagiere gegenseitig anstecken können
und zwar bevor die luft durch die
klimaanlage ausgewechselt wurde übrigens
gibt es einen weiteren entscheidenden
unterschied zwischen den klimaanlagen in
operationssälen und denen in flugzeugen
auch wenn in beiden die sogenannten hepa
filter eingesetzt werden in einem op
saal wird nämlich verhindert dass
partikel lange in der luft stehen können
frischluft wird ständig durch ein hepa
filter oben in die räume herr
eingeleitet und am boden abgesaugt und
aus geleitet so herrscht ein konstanter
luftstrom darauf sind flugzeuge gar
nicht ausgelegt es herrscht zwar ein
kontinuierlicher luftaustausch aber mit
einem operationssaal ist das bei weitem
nicht zu vergleichen
verschiedene wissenschaftliche studien
zeigen ganz eindeutig dass in den
vergangenen monaten verschiedene fälle
von kogit 19 ansteckungen in flugzeuge
stattgefunden haben so passiert
beispielsweise auf einem drei stunden
flug von hongkong nach peking mitte märz
mit 120 personen an bord eine an cupid
19 erkrankte personen hat der studie
zufolge auf dem flug 20 personen sicher
angesteckt zwei der angesteckten leute
saßen sieben sitzreihen vor der
erkrankten person und eine weitere
angesteckte person 5 sitzreihen
hinterher und das ist ein viel
realistischeres bild wenn man im
flugzeug mit einem coup 19 erkranken
sitzt ist das risiko also hoch zu diesen
ganzen wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
kommt ja auch noch der faktor mensch und
der ist quasi unberechenbar denn die
meisten kroner sicherheitsmaßnahmen
setzen auf die eigenverantwortung und
die ehrlichkeit der einzelnen passagiere
das zeigt auch ein fallbeispiel das weh
guardian die britische zeitung
recherchiert hat die redaktion hatte
eine person im interview
die sich auf dem vietnam airlines flug
infiziert hatte dieser hatte angegeben
dass er vor dem flug gefragt wurde ob er
sich vor kurzem in china italien oder
dem iran aufgehalten aber zitat was wäre
denn passiert wenn ich dort gewesen wäre
aber mit nein geantwortet hätte ein
großes problem ist auch die
nachverfolgung und selbst dann wenn sie
einzig und allein innerhalb von
deutschland erfolgen muss so waren
beispielsweise vier reisende aus einem
mallorca urlaub in nürnberg gelandet und
dann in ihre heimat cottbus gereist
dieser fall wurde zwar beim
gesundheitsamt nürnberg gemeldet doch in
cottbus ist man für die
kontakt verfolgung verantwortlich tja
und da wusste man von nichts
das fazit vom hamburger forscher hinter
scholz ist jedenfalls eindeutig wenn
jemand sagt fliegen ist auch in corona
zeiten sicher dann hat diese aussage das
niveau von renten sind sicher
studien legen allerdings nahe dass
reisen sie sich nicht nur selbst
gefährden es ist nicht auszuschließen
dass fliegen während der korona pandemie
erheblich zu einer zweiten
ansteckungswelle beiträgt keine frage
dass sich die ansteckung so rasend
schnell über die ganze welt verbreiten
können bleibt an dieser stelle nur noch
festzuhalten dass die aussagen und
argumentationen der luftfahrtindustrie
irreführend und vor allem auch
leichtsinnig sind für alle die
eigentlich gar nicht fliegen wollen aber
nicht drum herum kommen könnten die
folgenden ratschläge hilfreich sein im
besten fall in der letzten reihe am
fenster einen sitzplatz buchen und die
luftdüsen schließen während des fluges
nicht umher gehen sondern lieber sitzen
bleiben und außerdem mindestens eine
atemschutzmaske mit einem p filter
benutzen besser noch eine fb2 maske das
rät jedenfalls dieter scholz mundschutz
wegen co2 ungesund und noch ein thema
das heißt diskutiert wird anklicken also
hier anschauen und abonnieren
sehr kostenlos und zwar einfach medizin
top medizin kanal bis dann bleibt dran